all right I haven't mentioned anything
about this there's this maybe you've
heard about this cat fight between two
uh males Dylan Mulvaney and Caitlyn
Jenner a little background on this
milvaney did and I'm not even gonna play
it for you uh because even I have my
limits for the grotesque things that
I'll subject you to but he did one of
his grotesque ridiculous days of
girlhood videos
where he talked about going to the store
in tight pants and having a bulge you
know because he has a penis because he's
a man
um uh he wants to be a woman but his
penis was visible through his shorts and
this is what he was doing a video about
this and he said that um
this is why we have to normalize the
Bulge for women that was his uh that's
his you know campaign slogan that's the
banner that he's marching under now
Jenner responded to this by saying let's
not normalize any of what this person is
doing this is absurdity
and then in a follow-up he said he's
talking about his penis
which I mean pointed to the obvious
there thanks for that Jenner now this
led to lots of outrage on the left and
uh you know because generous calling it
absurd but also because generic quote
misgendered Dylan Mulvane referred to
him as a guy
um and Mulvaney responded to that we'll
play a little bit of of uh this this is
this one's a little bit safer I don't
think you start talking about his bulge
here but you never know with this guy so
let's watch a little bit of this
days of transitioning and remember being
embarrassed about your body or having
strangers give you dirty looks that's
why I made that video because I was
embarrassed and I wanted to reclaim my
body in a positive way and now you've
taken that and you've turned it into
something really ugly
and I didn't start days of girlhood
because being a woman sounded fun I
started this series because of the
unspoken shame of being newly trans I
still have so much to learn
and we come from very different
generations and you're so much farther
along in your journey than I am but I
have cheered you on from the second you
came out truly and I'm so happy that
you've had the surgeries that you've
desired but I'm 25 years old and I am on
day 233 I can't even get bottom surgery
right now if I wanted to I haven't been
on hormones long enough
and this whole situation makes me not
want to share my surgical plans because
there are so many trans women who don't
have access to it or they don't want it
and it doesn't make them any less of a
woman you know funny enough one of the
only things that we do have in common is
that I'm going to one of your surgeons
you know I'm just I'm not as far along
as you please be patient
and you know now that I think about it I
I don't even think I have interest in
getting to know you because the way you
use your platform to publicly degrade me
it it told me everything I needed to
know about you and uh a trans person
invalidating another trans person's
transness is pretty evil in my eyes like
the call is coming from inside the house
it's coming off very selfish you know is
no one else allowed to be trans I for
one am excited to welcome anyone into
our community because I know how
isolating it can be in this whole
situation it feels like the movie Mean
Girls I mean Halloween is right around
the corner so there's a costume idea for
us I guess I don't know I digress but
you've been accepted like you've been
accepted by a group of people that
clearly does not accept me and nearly
every day
uh yeah it's very isolating it's very
isolating for for Dylan Mulvaney to be a
girl
supposedly for 45 seconds and uh to be
greeted with you know adulation and
Applause and corporate sponsorships and
brand deals and and you know invited to
speak at Women's Summits very very it's
very feel very isolating and alone
no isolating along to be an actual woman
Maybe
I could see that as being isolated
making you feel isolated and lonely when
when you're an actual woman and you've
been living as one because you are one
your entire life
and then this guy comes along and just
jumps to the front of every single line
the left is losing their faith but we
are not and a core part of that faith is
prayer you know I talk a lot about
stressful things all day and you might
feel a little bit overwhelmed I know
that I do sometimes with where the
country is going but I've got good news
how low can help you find some peace and
hope rooted not in the government or its
institutions but in God hallow has over
5 000 audio guided prayers meditations
peaceful Christian music including the
rosary with Bishop Baron and Mark
Wahlberg the Bible in a year with father
Mike Schmitz minute meditations for
brief moments of Peace away from the
liberal media and much more Hello helps
you build a daily routine and a habit of
prayer it helps me to pray meditate and
sleep better it's a huge part of my
daily routine so you can get an
exclusive three-month trial of hallow at
hallow.com Matt Walsh that's hallow.com
Matt Walsh
well yesterday Jenner responded by
apologizing for misgendering Mulvaney he
tweeted an individual on Miss Jenner's
team haphazardly misgendered Dylan in
the Tweet he is talking about his penis
for this we deeply regret the comment
and have taken the appropriate actions
to rectify the situation internally
Miss Jenner has no further comment on
the matter and stands by her statements
otherwise
right someone on his team
well he is on his own team so I guess
that's accurate
you see
um
once again this is why Caitlyn Jenner
never should have been embraced by
conservatives because that's the real
like story here and I and I've seen some
conservative responders defending Jenner
he deserves no defense
really this is a story about the [ __ ]
conservatives the idiots who Embrace
this guy
and they just look dumber and dumber
every single day
never should have been embraced by
conservatives he is not a good Advocate
on this issue or on any issue but
especially on this one
okay to use the leftist terminology he
is not an ally
so these idiot conservatives think well
if we have a trans person come in and
criticize the trans agenda well that
that that's the trump card right there
that's the ace up our sleeves
no that's that's the last person who can
criticize the trans agenda is someone
who's actively promoting it
you know what it's like it's like um if
you want to do a News segment if you
want to do a television segment about
the problems of drunk driving and so you
have someone come on the air who is
currently drunk and drove to the studio
and you have him come on to talk about
the dangers drunk driving that is the
worst Advocate or that's the worst
person to talk about this issue
especially if he's talking about it by
you know you have this this drunk
bastard coming on uh criticizing other
drunk people
okay this is not someone you want to you
you want to have if you want someone to
to come on TV and you know extol the
virtues of moderation
it shouldn't be an actively drunk person
now you want to bring someone on who is
a recovering alcoholic used to be an
alcoholic has has uh gotten past it and
is recovering and can talk about
retrospectively talk about uh what it
was like to be an alcoholic you know as
someone who experienced it and got past
it that's different
just like if you want to talk about if
you want you you want to talk about the
transgender agenda
yeah and bring on a d-trans person
someone who was in that life and managed
to get out of it and can talk about it
again retrospectively
um well that's a great advocate
but not someone who is actively in it
right now
and promoting it which Jenner is
refers to him himself in the Tweet is
Miss Jenner
because you know what you're putting the
other side in a position where they're
right but Dylan Mulvaney said there most
of that is like basically right from
from from Caitlyn Jenner's perspective
he's right about that
because basically what he's saying is
wait a second if you get to be a woman
like why can't I
like where do you come off calling me a
he and yet you expect us to call you she
how does that work
he's he's actually right about that
that's what a brilliant Advocate uh
Caitlyn Jenner is he puts us in a
position where we have to he gets into
an argument with a guy like Dylan
Mulvaney and Dylan Mulvaney is right he
put He gives this this
be careful the words I use he gives this
individual the opportunity to be right
about something
that's how terrible Caitlyn Jenner is
that's not going to stop it yeah he's a
Fox News computer he's gonna stop Fox
from bringing him on
the worst possible person
hey I know you're uh craving some more
Matt Walsh show content while I have
some great news for you if you head over
to dailywire.com And subscribe now you
can watch or listen to my full show you
can also listen to my podcast on Spotify
Apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcast I'll see you there